[Música]
qué tal cómo están
la base se refiere un poquito bueno
porque lamentablemente sé que más del
90% de todas las personas que están aquí
sentadas pensaron que gustavo linares
era la persona que estaba junto justo
aquí en este escenario porque porque
desafortunadamente vivimos ahorita en
una sociedad en la cual discrimina a la
gente joven a la cual dice que gente que
tiene canas
es sinónimo de inteligencia es sinónimo
de educación es sinónimo de experiencia
laboral por ende se dice también que se
les criminal los millennials se dice que
no hacemos nada nos gusta trabajar desde
casa somos inútiles y es por eso que les
quise dar este tipo de dinámica al
principio porque es lo que me ha pasado
en el transcurso de mi carrera laboral
me ha tocado estar en eventos en el cual
siempre soy el menor
me ha tocado hacer entrevistas con
candidatos a la presidencia para
contratarles personal me ha tocado
trabajar en conjunto con cancilleres me
ha tocado trabajar con embajadores
trabajé con el jeque de abu dhabi cuando
trabajé en dubai
mi nombre es gustavo linares arizabalo
actualmente sobre el director de
recursos humanos a nivel nacional en
mexico y soy millennial
actualmente en el mercado laboral se
encuentran ya las cuatro nuevas
generaciones o las tres que hay más la
generación z que es la que está viniendo
se encuentran los baby boomers la
generación x y y ceta y ahorita podría
quedarme 23 horas en darles una cátedra
en como yo estoy en contra de este tipo
de estereotipos a mí gustavo linares en
lo personal no me gusta que se le
catalogue a ciertas generaciones como
'baby boomers' otra generación como x
otra con mi griega y otra como zeta
porque porque todos somos individuos que
somos personas que tenemos distintos
pensamientos queremos distintas
oportunidades en la vida queremos hacer
cosas distintas
queremos hacer un impacto en el mundo oa
lo mejor no hacerlo y porque catalogar a
todas las personas que nacieron dentro
de un rango de edad a que todos piensen
de esa misma manera yo soy un millennial
y me encanta usar trajes entonces yo ahí
que ya estoy rompiendo ese estereotipo
pero en vez de hacer medio la víctima
dije bueno tengo dos opciones si están
las cuatro generaciones ahora en el
mercado laboral pues tengo que acoplarme
y poder trabajar con ellos y poder
incluir sin una autoridad porque sé que
me veo muy joven vicente al principio
puede ser difícil pero también les
garantizo que todos pueden llegar a
obtener lo que ustedes desean si se lo
proponen y con humildad
es por eso que la clave del éxito es
llamar la atención de manera positiva
por más difícil que esto sea ya que me
refiero con esto bueno cuando somos
niños
uno puede llamar la atención de manera
negativa hay dos maneras de llamar la
atención que es de manera negativa y
manera positiva la manera negativa por
ejemplo es pues no voy a la escuela no
le hago caso mis papás y nahuel enfermo
no estudió me salgo de la universidad no
quiero trabajar en la manera positiva es
muy bien en la escuela estudio trabajo
hago deporte me beckham pero es más
difícil es más difícil porque les llevan
más tiempo en hacer eso
y con eso me voy a contarles mi historia
personal de como entre las naciones
unidas
de como entre dos naciones unidas pero
te los voy a comentar
que yo empecé como asistente de recursos
humanos aquí en méxico después de haber
venido de los siete países lo que yo he
vivido en todo el mundo llegó a méxico
empiezo como asistente de recursos
humanos
y estaba viviendo mi sueño mi sueño
siempre fue trabajar dentro de las
naciones unidas
al llegar me percato de una sola cosa
que éramos dos personas de recursos
humanos para 800 personas
claro sentí que me moría pero al igual
como les dije que tenemos dos opciones
la manera negativa y la manera positiva
dije bueno tiene o gustavo
o renuncia si te pones a llorar o haces
algo al respecto y luchas por tus sueños
y opté por luchar por mis sueños
entonces analice todos los hilos y todos
los placeres de oportunidad que podíamos
trabajar en el área de recursos humanos
para poder subsanar y poder arreglar y
ayudar a los empleados para que pueden
de ellos pueden permear y ayudar a todo
el país
al mes imprimirá 600 contratos me
tardaba dos semanas en hacerlo sean
nómina para ochocientas personas de
tratamiento selección y una vez dije
bueno gustado todo esto se puede sistema
sexting se sistematizan porque mi mente
es un software e imprima 500 contratos
en una hora
entonces ligue el sistema de nómina con
un software y
ya ese se construyó el software y ahora
en vez de hacerlo en una o dos semanas
ahora ya puedo imprimir 500 contratos en
una hora sin margen de error porque ya
viene de la parte de la nómina ese fue
la primera idea innovadora innovativa
eddie y por pura necesidad la verdad
porque ya me podría concentrar en cosas
más sustantivas que operativas también
me graben un vídeo que está en la
plataforma de la página web para poder
atraer talento hice alianzas con
influencers para poder poner nuestras
vacantes en instagram en diferentes
redes sociales para atraer más talento
joven a las naciones unidas hasta que un
día recibe una llamada de nueva york en
la cual me dice gustavo
hemos seguido hablar de ti
hemos seguro de tus ideas estamos
buscando alguien que venga a trabajar
naciones unidas por dos meses pero
queremos invitar a siento a los recursos
humanos de 280 países a nivel mundial
te interesaría participar en el proceso
claro que yo tenía miedo y les dije si
les dije que sí aunque tenía mucho miedo
porque porque sentí que me iban a
discriminar yo al llegar a naciones
unidas en nueva york yo pensando que
todo el mundo iba a ser de 50 años de 60
años que me iban a ver como el becario o
el pasante el interno de 23 años no
tengo 23 pero parezco de ver alrededor
esa edad entonces participó del proceso
más en exámenes entrevistas más exámenes
pasó una semana me llaman en essen
gustavo conseguiste el puesto nueva york
felicidades
entonces a la semana yo ya estaba
tomando un duelo
de mexico a nueva york iba trabajando en
mi celular recuerdo
con mucho miedo y al llegar a la sede de
naciones unidas
aquí yo les podría mentir y decir lo
políticamente correcto decirles de que
si llegué y era amor y paz
de parte mía no llegue con una
arrogancia una arrogancia que la verdad
se olía a distancias porque porque eso
decía ellos tienen la autoestima abajo
en relación a que yo me sentía menos de
todos los prejuicios que existen acerca
de los millennials me puse mi mejor
traje voy a entrando a la junta abro le
dice la puerta y recuerdo e imagínense
que había 50 personas en mayor de 40 50
años
1050 distintas nacionalidades
y me dicen gustado pasa enfrente tras un
minuto evita lo que estamos tratando de
hacer es mejorar nuestro proceso de
inducción a nivel global tú querías al
respecto
y el momento de verlos y analizarlos y
empezar a usar mi inteligencia emocional
y empezará a ver su lenguaje corporal vi
que había
directores de 50 años con jeans
no estaban juzgando mi manera de ver me
sino lo que ellos querían una solución
en una respuesta a ellos no me veían
como un millennial me veían como alguien
a la par entonces fue el momento en el
que agarré esa mochila que todos aquí
tienen aquí y saque todos sus prejuicios
el prejuicio de
soy incapaz porque soy millennial no es
lo suficientemente bueno no tengo ganas
me veo muy joven
si me quito la barba parezco de 20 años
todos los prejuicios me los quite y les
dije a ver
naciones unidas- méxico tenemos 800
empleados yo contrato gente desde los
cabos a cancún en todos los estados de
la república donde se dedican a cuidar
las tortugas las ballenas especies en
extinción pilotos marinos psicólogos
doctores todo tipo de carreras
contratamos pero les dije no todos
pueden venir a la ciudad de mexico por
ende yo me grabé en un vídeo de whatsapp
y les mandó sus inducciones a todos
ellos para que en 5 minutos puedan ver
qué es cuáles son sus prestaciones sus
beneficios y que son las naciones unidas
así que el piloto que está volando en
méxico o el marinero que está cuidando
las ballenas él puede ver por whatsapp
nuestra nuestro döring que es el curso
de inducción entonces les explique eso
es lo que hacemos en mexico ya si yo
tuviese el dinero para poderlo hacerlo
global lo que yo lo que yo haría sería
una aplicación porque porque ya la gente
ya no usa computadoras al martes desde
la universidad o la computadora que está
en el trabajo que es gratis ya la gente
no compra computadoras y aunque tuviera
una laptop o una computadora la gente no
va a estar en un camilla viendo su curso
de inducción o no van a estar en un
avión viendo qué hacer cuando lo están
no tienen acoso sexual pueden de todo
está en la palma de las manos con sus
móviles por eso yo haría una aplicación
y la próxima es propuse la aplicación
que pueden ver en la pantalla atrás mí
les dije bueno podemos hacer un embudo
de información que es las naciones
unidas a nivel global que es las
naciones unidas a nivel local cuáles son
las prestaciones los beneficios y
también las obligaciones de todos los
empleados también se lo estábamos dando
en más de tres idiomas para que gente
que estuviese en kuala lumpur en china o
en ghana pudiesen verlo en su idioma
natal entonces
también les puse las tablas de inducción
como pueden ver les dije bueno los
primeros 30 60 días a 90 días son los
más importantes para cuando entre un
empleado dentro de una organización
porque sí no
las estadísticas nos indican que
renunciar a esa persona bueno al momento
de venderles esta idea en menos de un
minuto se pararon y me dijeron gustavo
felicidades te quedas siete meses más
hay quienes ganan a ver espérense en
méxico va a decir que no porque ser el
jefe por suma 2 en méxico y me dijeron
no te preocupes vamos a hablar con país
y tú te quedas acá en nueva york
yo estaba contentísimo y la verdad dije
me quite todos los prejuicios y dije voy
a trabajar en esto porque va a ser un
impacto para más de 20.000 empleados a
nivel global un mexicano que viene de
una ciudad muy pequeña llamada tampico
tamaulipas logró estar en la serie
entonces al momento de estar allá me
pasa también algo donde aprendí mucho en
cómo poder influir sin autoridad y
también
aprendí mucho en que no hacer en
relación influir porque recuerden que yo
estoy en casa ajena en nuevayork
diciendo lo que yo pensaba es muy
importante decir las cosas con tacto
también para poder atraer la atención de
gente que queremos influir sé
así que lo digo también con este mensaje
que si quieren influir a otros a otros
ya otras personas debes de hacerlo con
un impacto positivo independientemente
de qué generación provengas aquí estoy
dividiendo que aunque esta es mi línea x
y z
dinosaurio lo que tú quieras puedes
hacer un impacto en el mundo ok
siempre y cuando sean positivos y porque
les digo esto porque cuando después de
que pasó un mes yo me puse a trabajar en
la aplicación todas las ideas me conté
con todos los directores a nivel mundial
de naciones unidas- de distintas áreas
y un día se me ocurrió algo brillante y
digo bueno esta aplicación
me junto con otra vez con los 50
directores top de naciones unidas de
recursos más a nivel mundial otra es mi
segundo danos los avances les digo ya
estuvo avanzando estuvo correcto estuvo
así pero qué tal si hacemos algo más
innovador yo tengo la idea de que
podemos usar la aplicación y despedir a
la mitad de los recursos a nivel mundial
se quedan como gustavo si podemos
inventar un tipo city y yo le puedo
llamar mini y se le puedo decir mil y
cuántos días de vacaciones tengo yo a
mensualmente y ni me va a contestar
cuentas con 10 días de vacaciones ni ni
cuando se expira mi contrato buenos
contratos expira el 31 de diciembre
entonces yo básicamente lo que quería
hacer era digitalizar
todo lo que hacemos todo eso todo lo
transaccional que hacíamos y disminuir
la carga laboral para los de recursos
humanos ahí fue cuando me llamaba
dijeron gustavo a ver aguanta
la manera en la que decimos la
incorrecta no puedes llegar tu venida
decir que quieres correr a la mitad de
recursos humanos a nivel mundial
y te puedes meter en muchos problemas
también entonces ahí es donde yo aprendí
que con humildad y con la mejor actitud
y esfuerzo todas y todos podemos obtener
lo que nos propongamos siempre y cuando
tengamos siempre presente la humildad
digo yo con esa arrogancia que se me
quitó la aprendí y aprendí de la manera
difícil pero nunca me voy a olvidar de
esa situación
en nueva york' y en todos los países que
he vivido y por eso vengo yo a decirles
ya dejarles el mensaje de que
independientemente de que yo estuviera
una escuela pública yo me pagué mis
estudios yo no estoy en harvard como la
mayoría de naciones unidas o en otras
escuelas llegué ahí nadie me discriminó
todo estaba en mi cabeza y todos ustedes
aquí pueden hacer un impacto positivo en
el planeta tierra y pueden innovar
independientemente de que hayan
estudiado innovación o no todos ustedes
pueden llegar a una solución yo estudio
administración de empresas y finanzas
he inventado más de 77 sistemas a nivel
mundial todos ustedes aquí presentes
pueden hacer un cambio siempre y cuando
lo hagan con humildad esfuerzo y la
mejor actitud muchísimas gracias
[Música]